are children who survived 40 days in the
Amazon jungle after their plane crash
they are beginning to tell their story
The siblings ages 1 to 13 a one-year-old
I know the baby was 11 months
born while he was in the jungle they
were found by Special Forces troops in
Colombia's dense rainforest on Friday
about three miles from the crash site
authorities and family members have said
the children who are members of an
indigenous group survived by eating
cassava flour and seeds and using a
bottle to collect water the flower was
in the plane and their knowledge of
fruit in the rainforest was key to their
survival according to an uncle the kids
said they hidden tree trunks to protect
themselves from snakes and mosquitoes
one of the kids said that their mom was
alive for about four days
crashed last month uh but then she told
them to go on and they did children are
expected to spend a few weeks in the
hospital where they're being treated but
they are said to be in good health and
in good spirits you